[Music]  have a seat mr mickelson  where would you like to go  you can be anytime you care to  [Music]  love is drawn in the form of a circle of  forever  always  and always  the past doesn't just belong to all  photos and history books anymore and we  can live it  touch it  change it  [Music]  wherever you are  whatever you are i will find you  we'll find our way back  what if you go back and change your past  but you end up with no future  i'm starting to forget my wife  [Music]  don't regret the past  that's what brings us to where we need  to be  we're all set have a wonderful trip  five  four  three  two  let's see what the past has waiting for  you  [Music]  foreign